الدم كما تبادل 50 اوكرانيا مقابل 50
محتجز روسيه ونرحب كذلك بالتماء الذي
استضافه التركيه في الحادي عشر من يناير
بين
امين المظالم الروسي والاوكراني حول هذه
المساله بالرغم من السياق المحفوف
بالتحديات مبادره
البحر الاسود الحبوب وحده تفارقه وتساعد
على خفض اسعار الغذاء منظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه تشير الى تراجعوا الاسعار اسعد
الغذاء فعلا 17 مليون طن من المواد
الغذائيه قد تم نقلها بموج بهذه المبادره
وصلت الى 43 دوله
عشونا في الماء من الدول المصنفه على
هذه المواد الغذائيه
كالدول منخفضه داخل
او في الفئه ما بين الدول المتوسط الداخل
تستمر الامم المتحده بتعامل مع الجهات
الفاعله
لتذييل جميع العرقيل امام تصدير الاغذيه
الروسيه والاسمده الروسيه بما في ذلك
الامونيا وهذه صادرات ستساعد على تجاوز
اعدام الامن الغذائي وستبقي الاسعار
منخفضه سيدي الرئيس
كما اوضح الامين العام غزوه روسيا
لاوكراني مثلا الامم المتحده ولقانون
الدولي لقد اد هذا الغزو الى كارثه
الانسانيه وكثر صح حقوقيه وهمم
اصابت كثير من الاطفال بالصدمه وعجلت من
حدوث في ازمه الصدقه وازمه غذاء
ولكن برغمى من ذلك هذا الضرر لا يقارن
بتداعيات
استمرار هذا المساء بين هذا
القطار المنطقه التي يسود هو المنطقه
العسكريه
ومن حيز اطلاقا الحوار
ولكن جميع الحروب
والامين العام مستعد لمساعده الاطراف على
انهاء هذا النزاع الذي لا طائل منه ولا
مبرر له على اساس النطاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي شكرا سيدي الرئيس
شكرا
سيدي الرئيس
وشكرا للسيده دي كارلو على احاطه
وافيه
زملاء مره عام والوضع في اوكرانيا لم
يتغير
323 يوما من حرب مستمر لمبرره لها
مما ادى الى
ضمار
طب انا ما حضرتكم كلمه وكيل الامين العام
للامم المتحده والذي اشارت فيها الى انه
لا حل سياسي يدور في الافق حتى الان
لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا ومعاناه
الاوكرانيين وقالت ان هناك تداعيات خطيره
ومستمره لهذه الحرب واشارت بجاز الى ضروره
تفعيل اتفاق الحبوب لمواجهه ازمه الغذاء
كلمه المندوب الامريكيه
ان تنقلوا ملايين الاطنان كل شهر فالجاعه
في جميع الحاله العالم يستحقون ذلك اليوم
اطلب من اعضاء المجلس ان ينضموا الينا في
حسي روسيا ان تعجل من التعاون في هذا
المضمار وفورا اذ نعمل على احتواء تدعيات
حرب روسيا علينا كذلك ان نركز على الاهوال
التي تقع في اوكرانيا على الارض في
الاسبوع الماضي مجله تايمز قد فصلت
الاهوال التي وصفت مكتب المدعي العام
والمرتبطه بالعنف الجنسي ضد الاطفال
والنساء
والرجال من قبل خواتي روسي الجميع الجميع
حول هذه الطاوله على الاستماع
او على بالاحرى قراءه هذه المقاله
التفاصيل مروعه ولا استطيع ان ارددها
اليوم طبعا
لا ينبغي ان نعول فقط
حالات من العنف الجنسي والتعذيب
في ليله الماضي حذرنا مجلس الامن ان روسيا
تستعد لاوكرانيا وحذرنا كذلك مؤخرا حضرنا
هذا المجلس مؤخرا انا ايران
وكوريا الشماليه
لنقل محظوره لروسيا وقد تم ذلك منذ اغسطس
نقلت ايران المئات من الطائرات المسيره
لرونيا في انتهى كان قرار مجلس الامن 2231
روسيا تستخدم هذه الطائرات المسيره
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
ولحرمان ملايين المدنيين من الكهرباء
والتدفئه والخدمات الاساسيه في خضم شهري
الشتاء الاوكرانيون همم يعانون ويموتون
نتيجه
ثاني ايران لروسيا نحن نعتقد ان ايران
تنظروا الان في بيعه مئات صواريخ
البالستيه لروسيا وكذلك كذلك في انتاج ان
قرار مجلس
ايران على عكس هذا المسار والا تتخذ هذه
الخطوات ونحس والجميع نحس كل من يدعم
السلام ان يطلب من ايران ان نستمتنع عن
هذه الافعال في تلك الاسنان
كوريا الشعبيه خطيه قالت انها لن تدعم حرب
الروسي على الاوكراني ولكن منذ ذلك الحين
قاموا بتزويد اسلحه لمجموعتك نرى وذلك في
انتهائكن لقرارات مجلس الامن في الشهر
الماضي جمهوريه كوريا الشعبيه ديمقراطيه
قامت بتزويد روسيا
بالصواريخ
لتستخدمها مجموعه
التي تدعم روسيا وذلك في انتهاكا
لمنظومه الجزاءات الامميه
توقف ايصال
مجلس الامن ذات اسئله مره اخرى
هذا العام الجديد
عادي اسبوع العالم من هذه الحرب الشعب
اوكرانيا والذي عاد الامر راين يطوق الى
الحياه العاديه
حان الوقت لجميع الدول ان
تتحد وان تطالب روسيا بانهاء هذه الحرب
التي لا طائل منها علينا ان نتحد لندافع
عالم ميثاق الامم المتحده وعن ما بديئه
الاساسيه يعني
لتحقيقيم سلاما عادل ودائن يتصفق مع
الميثاق الامم المتحده فلنبت القصاره
الجهود اللي احتواء اعتداعيات غير مباشره
لتصرفاتي روسي من يعانون في اوكرانيا وفي
خارج اوكرانيا وعلينا ان ناخذ بعض المسائل
كل من ينتهي هيك القانون الدولي وكل من
يدعم هذه الحرب غير الاخلاقيه وغير
قانونيه وشكرا السعاده
تويتر شكرا السيد الرئيس